you ever been a club guy i've never i've
never been a club
you know what i mean oh man awkward i
don't know so i first came to l.a i was
like like graystone and [ __ ]
you know you know what yeah it's just
yeah but you were like you know when the
ufc fighter days that that's the kind of
thing
it's at the club you know what i mean
you still come off as that guy
no i hated it hated it well for me like
it was like later when i started to like
you know
i remember i remember i was in vegas
with these two friends of mine these two
girls you know and they're like
one of them is like you know she's one
of those she told me the real story
about having to go to dubai and then she
told me the real deal
it's interesting yeah they bring you to
buy and then the guy was like okay
well you're here you know you gotta [ __ ]
everybody
[Laughter]
you know they get kicked out of the
hotel now they're at like a you know a
motel six
they told me to leave yeah that's like
you gotta go you know what i mean so
it's like
you say it anyways i'm in vegas with her
because they're just buddies of mine and
they go
i would now this is a high to
workaholics
and this is one of the reasons also i
don't like going out because
that age group at the time that goes to
bars and clubs and goes to vegas they
watch work
they love workaholics so they want to go
to this local bar in vegas and i go i
don't think we should go i don't think
it's going to be fun
you know and they're just like well you
know we want to go there hot [ __ ] you
know i said okay
you know sure enough they got us in the
bar oh [ __ ]
while you guys drink and then i go like
this is how i did it too i would take a
picture i would go like yeah she'll take
the picture
oh yeah yeah she'll take the picture for
you and then it turned into she was like
you know he's just trying to sit and
watch you know
you know he's a human being yeah then it
also turned into a thing where it's like
you know they
you know i don't care how hot you think
you are
i don't care how high you think you are
look around this bar there's a dime a
dozen of you hot chicks
yeah the only one montage in here yeah
yeah
you know what i mean so i don't care i
remember once i was in vegas and i was
like at this uh
i was at the taxi line you know there
was all these girls behind me and
they're young you know they were just
like you know
you know cackling like they're on a
chick podcast you know what i mean and
then like
you know i turn around just look at
something and one of them was like you
take a picture of stare much and i was
like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] please you know what i
mean
last longer you know and then their
boyfriends come up and they see me
and they go crazy they know oh [ __ ]
what's up and i was like all right take
a picture
then they're we're taking a picture and
i look at the girl and i go who's the
hot chick now
that's how you do it though what's up
dude you know you know what i mean it
was like
i'm not saying listen by the way i was
recognized
one out of 20 times in like regular
society so it was i
always thought it was the nice kind of
fame you know it was like just enough
not it wasn't crazy over the years there
were certain places
where they're they're sure the age would
be great it would just be like it would
be too much so i don't drink anyway
so i don't like going to bars and clubs
and then like i don't i'm not going to
be out here dancing and the music's too
loud and i'm like what you know
where where were we at because i know
you get uh anxiety being around bars and
crowd places
austin yeah and you know i don't like
crowded places not that i get anxiety i
just don't like big crowds i just don't
i don't enjoy it
in for a second i was like dude this is
stressful bro at my age you give me a
good
good meal some whiskey i can talk to my
friends i'm i'm [ __ ]
that's a dude i used to i used to have
jokes about this because it was like
i was at a certain because like when i
was on workaholics i was old already you
know i was like you know i'm supposed to
be an old guy but it was a hip young
show so i was like having these
experiences but i was like i never had
in my entire life
you know what i mean but then like i
remember this girl hit me up i was
single
all right let me just put that out there
and uh but it was like i used to do a
joke about it because she'd be like she
hit me up like at 11
30 p.m talking about hey me and some
girlfriends are getting ready to go to
the club you should come with us
and i'm like getting ready
i'm watching
my friends in vegas like hey we're going
to dre's opens at three i'm like wow
afternoon yeah like no after the club
ends
all the industry goes there i'm like
listen no thank you that ain't me girl
what happened
nothing good happens after three a.m and
then i'm like you want me to meet you at
the club you want me to meet you so
what i'm gonna look like you know what
am i i'm gonna look like somebody's dad
you know i'm walking around jenny
jenny you seen jenny
i know you're here judy you look like
somebody's father and i just
you just go it just doesn't make sense
you know just i don't know